en décembre 1993 un sondage commandé par
le magazine profession parents et france
info a révélé que les parents idéaux des
jeunes français seraient christophe
dechavanne et josiane balasko
ce qu'on ne savait pas c'est que
l'expérience avait été réellement
réalisés en secret à partir d'un
spermatozoïde et christophe dechavanne
et d'un ovule de josiane balasko
c'est ce que révèle le paris match du 14
avril 2014
le voici et nous accueillons le fruit de
cette union
paulette dechavanne
à
du coup c'est moi
ouais
mais pas coucou c'est nous tu as fait
bon voyage épouvantable pourquoi j'ai
failli imploser pendant ta télé
importations tu te retrouves un système
plus moderne à mon nom mais oui qu'est
ce tu faisais quand j'étais téléporté
dans cette émission rien je glandais
c'est tout enfin non j'essayais d'éviter
les vidéos ghazi parce que depuis que
match a lancé la nouvelle norme atx et a
vu que tu fait la cover
bah oui j'écris me lâche plus oui tu
sais bon des vidéos radis sont peut-être
surtout avant fin moi si j'étais invité
c'est aussi pour ça parce que des fois
on est l'enfant de l'amour mais toi tu
es quand même l'enfant d'une expérience
quoi wedin éprouvettes et dechavanne
c'est christophe cabot luc tu t'appelles
dechavanne
non ça c'est moi qui ai pas voulu parce
que je n'ai pas gardé le nom de josiane
parce que à cause de ses activités
politiques
on n'arrêtait pas de me relever la tête
avec sa relecture
ouais pourquoi des activités politiques
josiane balasko à des activités
politiques
oui mais comme tu suis josiane elle est
d'origine serbe et bas pendant la
dictature elle a accueilli plein
d'opposants ouais c'est sûr de milo
s'est dit oui
elle a même donné de l'argent à la
résistance et après la révolution en
2003 quand on à nuremberg ise milosevic
radovan karadic et les autres
purificateur et qui va briser sa vie à
cause du procès de nuremberg qui connaît
pas ce mot là toi non ça veut dire qu'on
juge un dictateur avant de le pendre à
d'accord et commencer la serbie
maintenant alors à belgrade c'est hyper
sympa bon ah ouais mais par contre les
autres bêtes c'est un peu genre un peu
j'en retiens monde tu vois ouais enfin
pennarun quand même calme ck one man
bois qui peut qu'attendre sur eric
burqin dans cette émission qui nous a
expliqué qu'en 2014 et vie des massacres
à sarajevo
écoute je suis pas on est en avril à
sarajevo et bien tout est calme se passe
rien oui ça m'étonnerait qu'il se passe
quelque chose difficile a finalement est
ce qu'il se passe jamais rien dans une
pomme et on apprend comment ça se passe
pour les bosniaques parce que en ce
moment une théorie quand même
calme en ce cas grec et bosniaques
bon voilà bonsoir vous voyez mpt de gaz
là il a des lunettes
alors voilà tout ça c'est vrai et c'est
vrai en effet comme ça 1 2 regardez sa
masse et sa masse est ton père qu'est ce
qui devient alors christophe batut sais
pas non mais non c'est vrai tu peux pas
savoir
en 2001 il a traversé la fing traversée
du désert ah bon
à cause de quoi tu sais pas enfin
maintenant il va mieux il a retrouvé du
boulot il a retrouvé du boulot et le
marketing sont rendus compte que les
jeux ça plaisait à la télé alors il a
été pris par ludovic chancel
ouais on sa nouvelle émission il a pris
comme comme faire-valoir tu veux dire
ouais ça c'est les gens qui aiment pas
mon père qui disent ah bon finalement la
question que tout le monde se pose c'est
que est-ce que c'est l'idéal d'avoir des
parents vidéo puisque à l'époque à notre
époque a nou là tu as été quand même pas
tes parents ont été choisis comme parent
ideo est ce que c'est idéal d'avoir des
parents vidéo mais je sais pas si
josiane et christophe c'était des
parents idée vous parce que j'étais
presque jamais eu un bon resto fils
avait ses affaires josiane sa politique
moi j'étais presque comme une enfant de
divorcés tu vois à bessan tentons
carmaux et ben j'en étais tout seul car
nous et cela est devenu carmouze bas il
est papa est né ludovic enfin ça c'est
pas le plus important pour moi c'est
quoi le plus important c'est lui qui m'a
élevé celui-ci car nous quitta élevé
mais ouais c'est lui qui est venu me
voir dans ma pension en suisse j'étais
tout seul
et aujourd'hui alors maintenant que tu
es grande qu'est ce que tu fais pas
grand chose tu sais un moment je me suis
senti aussi seul s'y abandonner ben je
me suis accroché au tabac s'était
accroché grave
et pas qu'un peu je te confirme à et à
lutter contre la dépendance au tabac
mais tu sais c'est l'horreur la
dépendance au tabac tue est capable de
tourner pendant pendant une nuit pour
toi et ton point et on veut surtout en
avait la garde
non c'est pas vrai prenons ça c'est pas
vrai alors ça c'est du bon ouais ça
c'est pas du froid c'est une espèce de
tarentule et mais pourquoi tu me l'avais
pas dit avant que dans aveux tu permets
que je m'en fais mine bah tu veux la
fumée la non tranquillement chez moi
mabut le fabuleux histoire quand même
une histoire extraordinaire extraire
mais justement et j'avoue que là il ya
quelque chose qui me dépasse
pourquoi si j'ai bien suivi toutes les
drogues dures même le tabac ont été
interdites en 2014 bah oui alors j'ai
quand même du mal à croire que les
téléspectateurs puissent encore
consommer en toute légalité du
dechavanne
il faut être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux